lose my virginity right this is this is
the game changer yeah i go i'm i'm the
guy lined up to start murder and [ __ ]
right right this is how my brain is me
too so i go i go
i go to have my first sex 17 years old i
go to put the condom on i can't get the
condom on yeah uh i unroll it all the
way and then i'm like that's it's too
big
yeah i've never put a condom on before
i'm like my mom rolls my socks up so i
rolled all the way
and then roll it back up you know four
inches and i'm like all right i go to
press it over and it inflates and i'm
like [ __ ] this isn't like this am i
making balloon animals at the corner of
a bed yeah girls naked i'm 17. i sell my
baseball jacket on and i'm like all
right [ __ ] it get another condom put it
on as i put it on i go oh reservoir tip
oh that okay all right i'm this makes
sense putting the condom on felt good
that felt good i get on top of her uh
i as i put it in i'm like
holy [ __ ] i as i pull out i blow my load
everywhere
and she looks at me and says
are you gonna put it in no i love my
dicks between her butt cheek and her and
the bed i didn't even [ __ ] a person i
didn't even [ __ ] person i didn't even
[ __ ] a person i didn't even [ __ ]
person swear to god i swear to god swear
to god swear to god and i had to keep
going i had to keep going i had already
compromised the integrity of this condom
and i had to keep going that's how i
lost my virginity i remember getting in
i'm 17. i remember going to the bathroom
looking in the mirror and going like
what the [ __ ] did you do what the [ __ ]
did you do it was so [ __ ] bad it was
so bad okay so that was one your wife's
another that's two i mean there was four
other girls total in your whole life one
was uh four in college and who else no a
girlfriend in college
girlfriend in college the one that gave
you the clap no no that was the
girlfriend that was a girlfriend in
college yeah so my wife this girl
girlfriend in college another girlfriend
uh a waitress
and a girl from liverpool
really yeah how long you been with your
wife though 20 years uh i'm not about
here's my thing is i have intimacy
issues so like when i'm using your head
would you get bopped off yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah i also don't
count like putting the tip of your dick
in a little bit and then going ahead
from a lot of girls
yeah i was fine with i was like
i was on the road when i was married
i've only been married on the road i've
never i even like
even
when i when i worked the door of the
boston comedy club i only hooked up with
like two chicks
but it was like also i don't know this
is gonna it's gonna sound whatever it's
gonna sound like but like i kind of
looked at it as weak that these comics
gave cared about [ __ ] like i was like
you you're doing stand-up because you'd
like because
yeah i think and i'll tell you right now
i've watched dudes throw their [ __ ]
careers away from postseason yeah i've
watched guys not get better because all
they want to do is their same act
because again
and i was lucky in that i met my wife
early but also i was like i've i mean
that's not my end goal i've always been
a drugs and alcohol guy yeah so like
that's always been my little bit my end
goal is like let's party tonight but
like i don't really give a [ __ ] i i
cared about comedy i remember watching
dudes
girl i'd see because i worked the door
i'd seat girls and i remember watching
guys
pivot their act when they saw the hot
chick yeah yeah and i remember going
they do their girl jokes yeah yeah yeah
yeah corny it was so corny and then and
and
i mean like like i made a joke through
the next i'm really into disc golf
is like any disc golfer any pro disc
golfer or any disc golf company anyone
who's into this golf can come backstage
and we'll talk disc golf yeah and uh and
it's funny man i had the guys over at
innova and they brought me out like you
know 50 discs and
we line them up and we're backstage at
the end of my show and i'm sitting with
these guys that are just disc golf
makers and professional disc golf
players and we're talking about disc
golf and i'm like there are guys that
are like
pointing to their bodyguard get that
chick backstage and that chick and yeah
that never was my thing you know yeah
yeah what do you think the combined
total of women uh you guys have slept
with you and the disc golf guys six i
would say
you're gonna say me and my wife i was
like we're in the [ __ ] 30s
guys thank you so much for watching that
clip from the flagger 2 podcast and i
just need to let you know it is march
madness and the national championship is
up for grabs and so is the bag with my
bookie sign up today at my bookie and
use the promo code flagrant to secure a
first deposit bonus up to one thousand
dollars it's simple deposit two hundred
dollars and play with 300 instantly just
use the promo code flagrant to claim
your bonus mobile or on the go college
or nba no matter the league no matter
the minute my bookie puts the action in
your hands so you can turn any game day
into a payday bet anything anytime
anywhere with my bookie
you